could bet Ben will be watching the Super
Bowl this Sunday on Fox that's where
Michael Strahan will be in the stadium
2400 miles away from his other Giga GMA
which is moving on from TJ Holmes and
Amy robot it can be tough if you're
already close to somebody and they're
not here
um that that can rock you a little bit
that can upset you a little bit but at
the end of the day you all have a job to
do and you understand this is a business
and whenever you start to think that
you're bigger than the business and then
the business bites you that's when
that's when it gets dangerous Strahan's
co-host Terry Bradshaw gave us a help
update after being treated for skin and
bladder cancer last year I'm good I just
left uh the hospital
yesterday and uh had another treatment
got no sleep I'm a little beat today I
guess but I'm good I'm cancer-free and
people don't realize what he went
through over the last year he's a
warrior he really is you just don't ask
the 74 year old Warrior about retirement
What would happen at the studio who
would take my place that's not ever
gonna what is wrong with you
one of Fox's newcomers this season was
Rob Gronkowski who was tagged in Tom
Brady's viral thirst trap selfie I don't
think he did it right his hand is not in
the right place he's covering up a
little bit you're not you're not
supposed to be covering up that's what's
supposed to be showing you got to show
the package Tom this is not Instagram
this is only fans we think it's a
midlife crisis well first of all I'm
jealous because I'm not 6'5 and skinny
uh I'm six tuned
working on getting skinny
now to the skinny on State Farm stadium
in Arizona where it all will go down for
the big game
[Music]
Rihanna has already begun her rehearsals
for the halftime show right there on the
field outside this place looks like a
spaceship and this 500 000 square foot
roof it's retractable inside the end
zones are already painted with Chiefs
and Eagles logos ready for Sunday's
kickoff at 6 30 Eastern one of the
really unique things about this stadium
is the playing surface it sits on a 19
million pound tray during the day they
Slide the grass outside and then at
night they bring it back in so it stays
warm takes about 70 minutes tickets
start at four thousand dollars a pop and
can go as high as 46 Grand expected
among the crowd of 73 000 stars like
Paul Rudd Kevin Hart Jay-Z and Ryan
Phillippe who this morning was packed
and ready now they don't call them
sweets here they call them lost and
there are 88 in the building and that's
where all the high rollers and big
celebs will sit during the game
of course taking center stage during the
pregame Babyface who will perform
America the Beautiful I got an exclusive
invite inside his studio for a look at
his warm-ups
[Music]
feelings
you want to sing No do you think I'm
gonna walk in here and sing in front of
Babyface no sir how excited are you
about the Super Bowl and Performing
America the beautiful I can't believe
that I mean I even got asked really hey
yeah it's crazy okay little secret I
heard that you performed it once before
myself more here
high school did it in a play called
fudge fudge well the version that you
will play differ a little bit it will
differ a lot
I promise I'm just going to keep it
simple and heartfelt
and check out the very special guitar
Babyface will play during his
performance it's a one of a kind
designed by Sue Thai I drew inspiration
from obviously the song that he's
performing so I turned the flag into
like the sea the mountain Majesty it's a
really great thing Chris Stapleton goes
from the Grammy stage to the Super Bowl
field for the national anthem Coda Oscar
winner and Arizona native Troy katzer
will perform in sign language and you
can expect a powerful rendition of lift
every voice and sing from Abbott
Elementary Cheryl Lee Ralph finish this
sentence for me performing at the Super
Bowl for me will be one of the greatest
things I will ever do besides marrying
my husband and birthing My Two children
foreign